guter letzt komplett stadion kommen zu
einem neuen video
ich habe für den fall das videomaterial
machen sollte rekord vorschlag war
tatsächlich macht kein video mit rewe
aber etwas kosten hier leute wieder
heute dafür netze etwa ein wirklich
jeder wir werden jetzt nicht gehen noch
andere wir werden wohl entweder mit
wahrheit antworten oder die körper
keine angst dann stimmt das parlament
[Musik]
war oder ist okay perfekt heute herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge pflicht
[Musik]
werden
direkt aber wir brauchten
naja ich hab eine schmutzige gab sie
können es genauso machen wie alle street
lkw-fahrers glaube ich mit 16 toten wird
wie sonst wäre aus meiner sicht
ich merke man normalerweise eher weniger
[Musik]
die wahrheit wird immer mehr zum küssen
würde nicht länger den boden mit dem
berater conti kamera dabei klug eichen
worden
de facto wird weil die mosel unter mich
dazu äußern was ich jetzt mache
[Musik]
leute das bei youtube etwa wenn ich
ehrlich bin hätte wahrheit was ein
lehrer packt war als ich erstmal mädchen
gefragt ob er gehen will
[Musik]
ich schwöre dir ich wurde nur bis 6 in
meinem schweiz leben leute bei 5.000
richtig und ich sage euch wirke vor
ich werde mich normalerweise eher
weniger noch nie so oft ich schwöre dir
ich wünsche dir jetzt merkt aber an die
eigene bad würde ich mitbekommen habe
kenne ich leute die hab ich wirklich
nicht entschuldigen
[Musik]
halver luig einem riesenproblem lade
vallori alle deine video also alle
videos und somit drin wird man
irgendwann die klänge gezeigt worden
ich komme nicht um einen kanal
irgendwann wirklich ein video meine die
wahrheit malen
ich werde dir holger stelle in amerika
verlegt ich würde auch gern vor so
drehen ricky perfekt dann würde ich da
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen der tür heute
definitiv das ein oder andere haben